hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about is ketosis
safe long term okay keeps coming up over
and over and over again now if you if
you take a look at what ketosis is it's
running your body on fat fuel okay not
just dietary fat but your own fat so
versus the regular way which use your
running body on sugar or glucose now
what do you think I mean it's just
bizarre to me that people think that
ketosis or fat burning is dangerous
compared to what what do you think
they're burning right now sugar burning
sugar fuel sets you up for high insulin
and out of all the illnesses or the
diseases why people die heart disease
Alzheimer's kidney problems cancer
stroke all those are related to high
insulin not ketones there's no bad thing
about running your body and ketones it's
actually the best fuel for the brain
your brain will run on a glucose but if
you give it if you drop the glucose down
and you run it on ketones which is the
byproduct of fat burning it's a much
cleaner fuel it's like running your body
on electric fuel versus sugar which is a
dirty fuel because you have the highs
and lows of the blood sugar so your
brain loves the ketones and that's why
they use ketosis in a lot of problems
with like epileptic seizures things like
that for kids because the brain chills
out when you actually feed it that in
fact all the people that just have
better thinking concentration focus when
they go in a ketosis diet and especially
long-term okay not a short-term thing
there is no long-term negative thing
about ketosis at all okay we'll cover
each point in fact it's one of the
original fuels our bodies ran on fat and
the way back you know in the and the
caveman days because if you think about
sugar the introduction of sugar in the
last hundred years it's like what a
hundred and forty nine pounds of sugar
per person consumed right now I mean
that's insane
so sugar fuel is created more problems
than anything especially with belly fat
so essential fatty acids okay so when
you're running your body on ketones
you're running body on fat the fat is
not just used for fuel it's used to
replace body parts cellular membranes
brain nerve tissue hormones are all made
from fat facile vitamins are made from
fat
there is no essential carbohydrate
hydrate that you need
there's no essential glucose people
think that well that's how you get
energy well you can get a lot more
energy from ketones a lot more efficient
energy what's the number one symptom a
diabetic complains that fatigue after
eating because the the high sugar just
puts you asleep and it puts the brain to
sleep it causes Alzheimer's it messes
with your your focus so you really don't
need carbs now you need vegetable
carbohydrates for the vitamins minerals
and trace minerals for sure but the
actual carbohydrate in there you don't
need okay and it's a myth that you know
it's dangerous and it creates a
ketogenic acidosis ketogenic acidosis is
basically a condition where your pH is
becoming more acidic from a diabetic
type one situation where you have no
more insulin you can't regulate it
that's completely different than doing a
ketosis diet healthily okay you're not
going to even get close to the amount of
acids which is a byproduct if you have
any insulin at all which you which you
do have it's not a problem so it this is
not even a factor in fact if you were a
type 1 diabetic or a type 2 this would
be the best diet to put put on because
what happens is the glucose that you're
running on burns out the cells that make
insulin
okay next myth is the muscle loss that
you would get on a ketogenic diet
ketones do not equal muscle loss in fact
when you do ketosis within a minute
fasting you increase the very hormone
that preserves protein especially the
muscle growth hormone so in termina
fasting increases growth hormone and so
it is the ketogenic diet if you're on
the regular glucose your diet or you
running on
bigger fuel which everyone is doing
you're going to raise insulin and
insulin will lower growth hormone and
cause more muscle loss take a look at a
diabetic or pre-diabetic they're losing
muscle tissue okay especially type 1
diabetics so we want to keep the insulin
low there's another myth ketones are
dirty sugars clean now it's just the
opposite
ketones are clean and it's like running
your body in sugars like running your
body on diesel fuel it's dirty
especially it gives a lot of byproducts
in the whole metabolic pathway some
people say that ketogenic diets create
deficiencies yes they do they do require
different machinery different nutrients
different B vitamins more minerals okay
but as long as you have enough
vegetables and maybe you're adding more
minerals potassium and B vitamins you're
totally fine I mean think about what
happens when you're you're running your
body on glucose you're depleting
potassium you're depleting magnesium and
you're depleting B vitamins and calcium
when you eat sugar
ain't like incredible in fact when you
have insulin resistance you don't the
insulin doesn't pull in the amino acid
or the potassium or the magnesium
anymore so really it's just the opposite
glucose running about in glucose crates
weigh more deficiencies and here's
another point about raising cholesterol
your body makes massive amounts of
cholesterol every single day for a
reason because it acts as a precursor
for hormones it acts to help repair the
tissue especially when you get older
it's the building block for stress
hormones especially and our bodies make
the amount of cholesterol that would eat
equal one pound of that butter or 300
strips of bacon or fourteen eggs a day
so if cholesterol is so bad why does
your body make so much so it's not true
that ketosis will increase your
cholesterol in fact what really makes
cholesterol is the sugar in that refined
glucose and the carbohydrates if you
don't believe me go ahead and cut out
the desserts cut out the sugar for one
month recheck your cholesterol and
it'll come right down to normal then we
have the kidney stone so people say oh
yeah the ketogenic diet creates a kidney
stones if you're a vegan okay or you're
running and running glucose you're
running you're actually having more ox
with stones guess guess what foods are
high in oxalic spinach beans grains
chocolate and any any carbs that
increase sugar or insulin will actually
increase uric acid stones so in reality
ketogenic diet will protect you the only
thing you need to do is you have to
consume some lemon juice just to start
to help you balance that out a little
bit more alright so I just wanted to
cover some key points ketosis is is the
only way to be healthy long term and I
think you should learn about it get all
the details do it healthily and add in a
minute fasting add more vegetables and I
think it's going to you're going to feel
better and you're going to look better
thanks for watching